HOST: Migrating to cloud can
be intimidating with a ton
of things to worry about.
How can you build
a solid foundation
for a seamless migration?
Well, keep watching to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Cloud Migration 101,
where we share migration tips
and tricks.
When planning your
migration to Google Cloud,
you need to understand
some concepts related
to cloud architecture.
A poorly-planned foundation
can cause your business
to face delays,
confusion, downtime,
and can put the success of
your cloud migration at risk.
But today's episode, I
have brought a friend
from Solutions
Architect Team who
will walk us through building
our cloud foundations.
Grasp as much as you can, and
I'll see you on the other side.
TRAVIS: Hi, I'm Travis.
When migrating from an
on-premises environment or colo
managed data center
to the cloud,
there are many
things to consider
from the IT, engineering,
and business perspectives.
Today, let's cover
the topics that an IT
manager needs to think about
when migrating to Google Cloud.
There are a few questions
you want to ask yourself.
First, how do your
existing business
and organizational structures
map to Google Cloud?
Second, who from your team will
control, administer, and audit
access to Google
Cloud resources?
Third, what are best practices
for managing multiple teams
working simultaneously on
multiple Google Cloud projects?
Let's start with
the first question.
How do you model your existing
business and organizational
structures in Google Cloud?
You'll want to map
your existing lines
of reporting and communication
to your resource hierarchy.
The resource hierarchy
provides structure
to your cloud
environment, determines
the way you are billed, and
establishes a security model
for granting roles
and permissions.
It's like the skeleton for
all your cloud resources.
For example, a Compute
Engine VM is a resource
which falls within a project
and folder, and all of these
are contained within
an organization.
Now, how do you control
access to cloud resources?
Once the resource
hierarchy is in place,
you can apply
security permissions
at each of these levels.
These permissions are then
inherited by any child objects
in the hierarchy.
For example, if you get
full admin privileges
on Department Y's
folder, you will
have full admin privileges
on all of the projects
and resources below it.
These hierarchies can be
as complex or as simple
as your organization requires.
A member is who or what you
want to give permission to.
A role is a collection
of specific permissions
to determine what operations
can be performed on a resource.
And a policy binds one or more
members to a particular role.
Once you have a
policy, you'll be
able to clearly define who
can do what on what resources.
As a simple equation, members
plus roles equals policy.
Let's take a specific example.
An enterprise wants to create
a policy for controlling access
to all of their
virtual machines.
They might use Instance Admin
and App Engine Admin roles.
Then they can create
a Google group
for the Ops Team that
will manage the instances.
And the policy would link the
members and the roles together.
They could then create
a read-only policy,
including Log Viewer
and Instance Viewer
roles for their
support team members
and, perhaps, a policy
with the Pub/Sub Publisher
role for the service account
of one of their microservices.
That would be three
separate policies.
That's the relationship
between IAM
and the resources,
projects, and folders.
Now, once you have the
resources in Google Cloud,
the question comes, how
do your teams actually
interact with them?
There are four ways to interact
with Google Cloud Services,
and your IAM permissions
will control what
you can do with all of them.
First, we have the cloud
console, the graphical user
interface that lets you
interact with Google
Cloud within your browser.
Second, we have
the cloud APIs that
provide programmatic
interfaces for interacting
with Google Cloud from
your application code.
Third, the cloud SDK, which is
a developer-friendly software
library that enables your
applications to interact
with Cloud APIs.
And lastly, we have the
G Cloud command-line tool
that lets you make
calls to the cloud API
directly from your command line.
HOST: That was great, Travis.
Thank you.
TRAVIS: Thanks.
You take it from here.
HOST: I got it.
Well, today, we learned
about resource hierarchies,
access control,
permissions, using IAM,
and the four methods of
interacting with Google Cloud
Services.
Want more details?
Check out the entire
guide linked below,
and stay tuned for
the next episode where
we will talk about
building a landing zone
and running your
workloads in cloud.
In the meantime, give us a
like and subscribe to NeverMiss
Google Cloud Migration Tips.
[MUSIC PLAYING]